a blockbuster ipo on wall street
electric vehicle maker rivian opened
with a share price that valued at around
91 billion dollars that's bigger than
fellow u.s firms general motors and ford
although ford along with amazon is a
major backer of rivien so let's find out
more about the firm that's got tesla
checking his rear view mirror
pickups and suvs rivian knows what u.s
car buyers prefer
in mid-september after a year-long delay
its first vehicles came off the assembly
line in illinois the electric car maker
now needs billions for the next phase
i think rivien is in a great position to
be going public right now first of all
enthusiasm for evs among investors is
really high right now and we've seen
that with the debut of dozens of ev
mobility stacks over the past year and a
half but even among that crowded field i
think rivien rises to the top and i
think it's one of the best positions ev
startups for a few reasons number one
they're extremely well capitalized
having raised just over 10 billion
dollars so far
and this ipo will enable them to add
even more to that war chest
the 12 year old company from california
has some heavy hitting partners
including ford and amazon amazon owns 20
of rivien and has already ordered a
hundred thousand electric delivery
vehicles these are currently being
developed
the cash injection from the ipo will be
used to crank up production of rivien's
high-tech and somewhat luxurious
vehicles
electric pickups offer an opening in the
market
tesla has had to continually delay the
production start of its pickup range
established car makers like ford and
general motors expect to launch their
own versions soon